[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is jill cardman
reporting from columbus circle in the
heart of new york city
and because i am now a broadcast
journalist i'm going to talk
like this jane three quick questions for
you
nacho table delicious or disgusting
disgusting disgusting delicious
your thoughts blake
it's delicious because you get to enjoy
nachos but it's disgusting because
the pandemic so you only should be doing
it with people what about if there was
no rona
delicious
next up on the debate docket foam
furniture
art or garbage i'll go for art
garbage art garbage it doesn't even seem
like it can hold anything up
garbage trash leg washing in the shower
do you scrub your legs or do you let
gravity do it for you
i scrub my legs describe my legs
absolutely for sure
really yeah yeah do you not scrub your
legs no
wash my legs and my feet and my toes
jane is clean i scrub my legs is there
another answer
scrub absolutely i'm afraid i'm gonna
stay scrub too because especially in new
york city you're walking around
you gotta do a little now i'm glad i'm
glad we both fell on the same side of
that one this guy better wash his legs
with all that
winged rodentia yo taxi
literally yeah perfect thank you
ladies and gentlemen my sister not
in law jill kargman
[Applause]
i mean are you freaking out or are you
freaking out i'm freaking out i need
a brown paper bag to hurl okay cause
like
literally this is really doing it for me
so you're a
nocho not a nacho i'm a no cho i would
eat these if they were hot out of the
oven and just for me
but the idea of 20 sneezed on rona hands
fishing into it is not appealing
i do think this is the worst time for
the nacho
yeah a crack of dawn yeah it's not it's
not
20 20 is not a friend to the nut no it
is certainly
not um because this is the thing like
people really really
do this whole nacho table thing yeah
it's a tick tock trend i didn't know
about it and then when i watched a few
of the reels to
educate myself i was holding involved
right
well for your reporting and all of our
kids are you know our kids are cousins
so um and they're the silly cousins and
they're besties and they're so close
they've been born like literally like
they're
they're just like i don't know they're
just
they're a pod they're a pod um and so
i'm sure they know all about this
all right the washing your legs
okay so this was a big shocker to me
every single person we interviewed said
that they scrubbed their legs in the
shower
and i never realized that i was frodo
baggins and totally filthy
because i just lather up everything else
and just let gravity do the work for me
and they looked at me like i was
slithering out of a rat hole
by the way i am in that rat hole with
you i'm a total gravity leg washer
totally i mean once like if i'm in a
bath i might use a scrub
once in a while but in the shower
there's all the shamps and the body wash
and it does it for you
totally last night i actually sat down
in my shower and because i do like to
clean my toes out like that
is a daily thing but the soap running
down i'm just like we're done
yeah i don't even clean my toes because
i feel like i would slip or something i
mean
i had to sit down i felt you know i was
you know
and it was weird because then the water
it's weird that the water at that
distance feels good but then
down there i never knew people sit in
the shower when they're like not sobbing
i don't yeah exactly i totally agree
with that glenn close
and uh yeah there should be some rocking
backing
that trained me to cry in the shower um
well thank you
[ __ ] for taking that six-foot mic and i
want to throw it to emma and say thank
you because i
loved the mic oh foam table garbage or
art
garbage soups
[Music]
you